let us start today's
session of synthesis of models and
systems
and our focus today is going to be on
probabilistic techniques synthesis
techniques and
we are going to have a quite uh four
distinguished speakers
and uh i would like to start first with
uh
yes peter catoan uh who is a full
professor
at urban university and the head of the
software modeling and verifications
the moves group he's also part-time uh
associated with the former methods and
tools at university of
20 and holds a honorary doctorate from
albert university
the speaker is since 2013 uh
distinguished
professor at everett hervetiah and he's
a member of the
academia europea he's also a recipient
of the erc
advanced grant and the research of your
speaker includes formal methods
model checking software verification and
synthesis
program ballistic programming and
concurrency theory so
there is much more that i could say
about your speeder but
let me stay somewhat brief and give the
floor to your speeder so your speeder
the floor is yours yeah thanks a lot
rydo for the introduction
i'd like to talk today about the
synthesizing probabilistic models and
programs and this is joint work with
mirandesca
roman andreyoschenko both from brno
university of technology and
from sebastian numerous is nowadays at
berkeley
um i'd like to start with an example and
that's about a randomized distributed
algorithm and the question is how to
pick
the optimal bias so i want to look at
what our so-called self-stabilizing
distributed algorithm
and just for your remembering what is a
self-stabilizing algorithm
it needs to be able to start from an
arbitrary state
for instance the initial state and then
converts to a so-called legitimate state
so in the token ring a legitimate state
is for instance this
thing with a state with a single token
and then there is a closure property
that says
the system will stay in such a
legitimate state
in absence of any faults and actually
this is a key concept
in fault tolerant distributed computing
there is even a conference that is
completely devoted to self-stabilization
um so there is this seminal paper by
dijkstra
in the mid 80s um
who showed that self stabilization in
anonymous networks
networks where you cannot yet say use
the identities of the nodes is
impossible
so this is an instance of such an
impossibility result
like fisher lynch and paterson in in
distributed computing
and the solution by ted hammond was
why don't we use randomization
so consider that we have a ring and here
is an example of such a ring
and read it in a clockwise manner and we
have an odd number of processes
each process has a boolean variable and
the only thing you know
is your own variable as well as the
variable of your
left neighbor so anti-clockwise neighbor
and that's all you have and then there
are tokens
the black dots which i'm explaining in
the middle in a minute
so the algorithm is basically only two
lines so what does a process do
they all do the same if your value is
the same
as that of your neighbor then you flip a
biased coin
if your value is different than from
your neighbor then you just copy the
value of your neighbor
and that's it and then a process is
possessing a token
if your value equals that of your left
neighbor
and what are we interested in we are
interested in what is the expected
number of steps
until this algorithm is going to
stabilize
good so here you see just for you wanted
to see whether you understood the
algorithm
suppose we have the configuration uh
over here
then we first all the processes
without a token so those that differ
from color so for instance this one has
a different color than its
neighbor because it's red so it turns
red
and the same for instance for this
process it has a different color than
its neighbor
so it turns red now all the
processes that possess a token they flip
a coin
so we go in the direction so this
applies to the two green ones and the
red ones
and for instance this one apparently
uh it still is green that's the value of
the local variable didn't change
but for this process apparently the coin
flip said i have to change my value
because it turns from green to red
and now what we have to do is we have to
basically
assign the tokens so that means that
every process that has
the same color as his neighbor now is
going to get a token
so for instance this process is red its
neighbor is red so this process is going
to have a token
good in this step we didn't gain
anything because we started with three
tokens and we end up with a
configuration of three tokens
but you can imagine that in another
let's say possible
outcomes of the coin flip we indeed get
from the situation where we have three
tokens to a situation where there is a
single token
good well what you can do is and this is
what this table shows
you can automatically determine for
which
bias of the coin you minimize the
expected number of steps to stabilize
and that's given over here and here you
see different ring sizes
and this is the size of the model and
what you actually have is here a kind of
a markov chain
but the probabilities are unknowns they
are variables and those are the ones
that you synthesize
and how to do that we use abstraction
refinement kind of techniques
i don't have time to go into details
here what is important that you see is
that for certain ring sizes you get
basically two regions of parameters so
apparently there are two values for
which you get a minimal
expected convergence time
actually what we do we do and here you
see the curve which is the blue curve
you basically try to abstract this
these are the yellow boxes and then if
they're not detailed enough you try to
refine those boxes which is the picture
on the right bottom in which you refine
the kind of regions in order to get more
precision
that's intuitively what's going on and
you continue this
until you're happy with let's say the
amount of
coverage of your of your algorithm
concerning the parameters
so what you get is a picture like this
on the x-axis you have the bias
on the y-axis the expected recovery time
or the convergence
time and what you see is that for small
ring sizes
the one over here or the one over there
um actually there is one minimum
namely a fair coin is optimal but you
see that for larger ring sizes for
instance this one
i mean two values are actually optimal
and they're actually you have to use a
bias
to minimize the convergence time
good so you can automate this process
and you can automatically synthesize the
parameter values
that minimize the expected convergence
time in these algorithms
but probably we would like to do more so
the instance i just showed you
is an instance of parameter synthesis
where you have a probabilistic model
like the markov chain on the left
and in the markov chain you're typically
interested in the probability to reach
a certain target state like for instance
this state
or you're interested in what is the
expected number of steps to
end up in that target state instead in
the parametric setting
what we have are parameters so here is
the bias of the coin
x and one minus x you're still
interested in for instance reaching that
state
but now we're interested for which
values so for which bias of the coin
can we reach our target state with a
certain probability and let's say that
probability lies
among one over six and then what you can
do you can actually synthesize and what
you get is actually a rational function
in the parameters and you're going to
check for which values of x is this the
case
and what we get actually here is an
uncountable set
because the variable x can have a real
value so we have uncountably many
possibilities of finite markov chains
the markov chain itself is finite state
instead what we are currently looking
also want to look at
is actually what happens if i also allow
topology cases topology changes
so typically um the cases where x equals
zero or x
equals one that would mean that actually
you would delete one of these edges
over here is typically excluded so that
means those parameter synthesis problem
need to be
topology preserving
so what if we also allow topology
changes right and that actually means
we're not tweaking the parameters but
we're actually tweaking the control
structure in terms of a program
um so the idea is that again we have our
markov chains but now it's possible to
basically adjust certain parameters
so rather than having this backward adds
to s2
it now goes back to the initial state
and of course i could also
define this going to this state rather
than going to the initial state and so
forth
so in fact what we actually have is now
a huge
but a finite set of finite markov chains
in contrast to this
uncountable set of finite markov chains
before in the parameter setting
good so what are we interested in we're
interested in as input having such a
markov chain family
this huge huge set of finite markov
chains
and a given property the property could
for instance be
we want to reach a specific good state
with
with a particular higher probability and
now we're interested in things like this
we want to find one markov chain in the
family for instance this one
that satisfies our specification
or we want to be interested in finding
all realizations satisfying the
specifications so in a sense we want to
partition
our family into the good guys and the
bad guys
and similarly we want maybe to want to
find the realization with the maximal
probability to reach g
and that could for instance be this
instance yeah or
something like this and then you can
imagine that
in fact certain topology changes come
with certain costs
and maybe we're interested in finding
the cheapest one satisfying the
specification
or the one that fits a certain budget
that we define
a priori so these are the kind of things
we are interested in
um so the way to view this is that for
instance if we have two parameters one
on the x-axis
the yellow one and one on the y-axis the
red ones
and in this case we have 18 different
variants then we are interested in
finding for instance one of the
members in the family satisfying the
specification
so um we're interested in for instance
this is for instance one instance from
the family this could be friends of the
topology on the right
uh this could be another instance of the
family that's the other topology right
you see the difference
in the in the red arrows or this could
be yet another family
good i think this setting is clear and
now what we want to do is we want to
partition the parameter space
so we want to determine which ones
satisfy our specifications
and which ones are going to reject or
violate our specifications
so the baseline is very simple right you
fix the parameter build the model and
your model check
so you just pick one instance this is
good for instant be your instance
you discharge this to a model checker
and the moto checker tells you
this model refutes the specification
then you take the next one
and maybe that one satisfies the
specification and so forth
now this of course is a very simple
strategy but it's not using any of the
structure from the family and it's not
going to scale
so another approach would be well you
just take for instance those
four family members and you're going to
model them in one shot which means
basically
that you're going to add one state here
where you build a non-deterministic
choice between the different family
members
and that actually has proposed by people
working on on software product lines
um this exploits some regularity
and you can use for instance symbolic
methods for doing that but
it still yeah does not scale very well
to large models
so we need to be a little bit more
advanced to solve our
thing so the first idea is to use
abstraction
so the idea is not to represent those
four explicitly and then have one
deterministic choice
but rather basically
provide an abstraction where we forget
the exact realization the family member
we are currently in
so we represent those four family
members by a single model
this model is now a markov decision
process because it has a
non-deterministic choice because for
instance here there is a
non-deterministic choice
between having those two arrows uh
for instance in the model and so what we
have is we have
this non-determinism here now we have to
be a bit careful
because if we resolve the
non-determinism of course
the resolution should be such that the
resolved model indeed is a family member
and not something some model which is
not in our family
but that's basically the key idea the
first idea to use the kind of
abstraction
good and this yields what we call a
quotient markov position process it's a
quotient
because of the uh of the of the whole of
the whole basically family
so now what we can do using this
quotient is applying a technique which
is called abstraction refinement now
this has been developed already for
probabilistic models
earlier so let's see what is special
about what we are doing
so what we do is we take such a family
and we model this by this abstraction as
i just
showed you so we start with one
abstraction and here we have a queue of
those abstractions
because what happens in our technique is
that we're going to
yeah gradually iteratively refine the
quotient so in the end actually we have
the set of those quotients
now we pick one element we discharge
this to a verifier
the verifier in green will check whether
the
model that we actually took is actually
which is an mdp
right it's a micro decision process
satisfies our specification or not
and if it indeed satisfies our
specification
then we have found an instance
satisfying our specification
if it's not the case well then we have
to go back
and select another quotient and if the
outcome is inconclusive
then the idea that we're going to refine
the whole quotient family and that means
that we're going to split the family in
several parts
if in the end we have checked all
possible quotients
and that quotient set is empty then it
turns out that our synthesis problem is
not satisfiable
good i'm going to skip this picture so
what's the id
basically this is the entire family
suppose that this family contains these
members
some of the members reviewed the
specifications some of the members
satisfied the specification and this was
our threshold for instance larger than p
that is the situation individual
situation that's not the
situation that we view because the only
thing that we have
at our disposal is the whole family
actually the abstraction of the family
so the only thing we get by model
checking is a minimum
and a maximum and from that we can
conclude
basically nothing so we get as a result
inconclusive
so what are we going to do we're going
to refine the family into two parts
and for instance we're going to look at
these family members
now suppose that those family members
are over here
that means in our abstraction we get
again a minimum and a maximum
all the i mean the maximum is smaller
than the threshold which is over here
which means that all the family members
over here reviewed the specification
so in one shot we can decide that
actually those
are actually refuting the specification
and now the whole scheme is is continued
now you look at this blue part suppose
that this is the situation
and here you see the result will again
be inconclusive because we have both
satisfying
and refuting family members so actually
we need to refine
and we do this until at the end we get a
from
a subfamily like the two over here that
for instance satisfy the specification
so in this way we actually abstract we
start with
an abstraction of the entire family and
we gradually refine it
so that we get sub families either
satisfying or rejecting the
specification
another technique that we are
considering actually is sigis
where the idea is that we don't use this
abstraction at all we just take the
family as it is
so that's my family of finite markov
chains or finite programs
and now what we do is we pick an
instance we use an oracle to pick
a certain instance and we discharge this
instance to a verifier now notice that
in my case this instant now is a markov
chain
right we don't use abstraction here it's
just a markov chain
we discharge this to a verifier if the
firefighter says
accept then we have found a realization
satisfying the specification
if the verifier rejects the
specification it also will give you a
conflict a kind of a counter example and
actually we are going to use that
counter example to not
only rule out the candy date that we
just have checked
but actually we want to rule out the
whole in this case the sub
candy dates or many of the candidates
and that's actually this
this blue area over here
of course if in the end no realization
is left it means again that my
problem is not satisfiable and that
means that
uh yeah we did not find any family
members satisfying this specification
root um a short word about counter
examples what is a counter example in
the context of
probabilistic models well that's a
little bit harder than for
non-probabilistic models
so if we write for instance a program
and this is a probabilistic program
and then what is a country example of
such a probabilistic program that
refutes a certain specification well
that actually is a sub-program
and preferably you would like to have
this sub-program as small as possible
so we're interested in finding a minimal
command set of this program
notice that we do not determine the
counter examples at the markov chain
level
we determine the contract examples at
the program level
i think that's an important asset of
this technique
so this is a hard problem so there are
several techniques so for instance you
can use a mac sub problem uh a mux out
approach
or you can use a kind of greedy approach
to find these kind of
examples kind of country examples so
here is an example
of a couple of numbers where you see
four different models over here
with different states space sizes and
different numbers of transitions
so here in the first red thing you see
the number of transitions
but what is most important is over here
where this entrance actually says that
is the size
the number of edges of the size of the
minimal command set so to speak
and on the right so the one in let's say
yellow
is the one that you compute so you're
not always able to compute really the
minimal one but hopefully you get close
to the minimum one
why are we interested in those those
minimal ones well because we
basically exploit the following property
in terms of a markov chain
remember we don't determine counter
examples on the markov chain level but
we do this at the program level
but in terms of a markov chain a
counterexample is a kind of a stock
markov chain
and the idea is basically all markov
chains that share this sub-markov chain
will refute the safety property so the
smaller
those sub-markov chains will be the
larger the possibility will be to rule
out many family candidates in one shot
if you do synthesis
so that's the reason why we are
interested in this minimal
command set and we're not just
interested in arbitrary counter examples
okay i hope that clarifies the setting
actually what we also recently did is we
tried to combine the two approaches
let's call we call this the best of both
worlds
where we have a learner in yellow and we
basically have two oracles
the abstraction oracle the oracle i
showed you
in the beginning that uses an
abstraction of the family
and we have this counter example oracle
on the right
and in light blue that is able to do
basically this sigis-like
approach and now what this combination
um
allows you to do is actually uh for a
while to do sigis and if sigis cannot
let's say progress anymore or not fast
enough
then we can use the abstraction oracle
and we can also use
results from one oracle to speed up to
accelerate
the synthesis by the other oracle
um this looks like us i mean
conceptually quite simple
i mean if you uh let's say the details i
mean too is actually quite laborious and
and quite intricate to find out and to
make this work
efficiently this all has been
implemented in python
using z3 as as a satisfiability checker
and the probabilistic model checker
storm to do the to do the model checking
underneath
so we used this storm model checker
here is a plot from a recent
tool competition or tool a comparison of
of model checkers where on the x-axis
you see the number of instances
and on the y-axis you see the amount of
time
needed to solve these kind of instances
and notice that the y-axis actually is
log scale
so we use the one that corresponds to
the red curve which
is the storm model chip so i would like
to give you three short examples
first of all here is a program which is
about
a dynamic uh program dynamic power
management
so actually we are interested in uh
synthesizing this power manager
here you see a model which it can be in
four different power modes
there can be jobs they will be entered
in those queues
we have high priority and low priority
queues
so we have low priority and high
priority jobs
if the queue is full you lose a job so
what are you interested in you're
interested in
yeah minimizing the probability that the
q will be full because otherwise
you lose a job and you would like to be
able to minimize the expected
energy consumption so in terms
of the challenge is we are basically
synthesizing guards
and assignments in such a control
program
and this specification which is
basically a control program with
with a number of holes so it's a program
sketch where you start from
and the specification is what i said
just before
a conjunction of expected number of lost
requests and the energy consumption
so just to give you some numbers and in
total this number i mean it's not
19 but i think it's 16 parameters um
43 million control programs so the
family
consists of 43 million markov chains and
each markov chain of this average size
now if you would just do the naive
approach by model checking every
individual program this will take you
more than one month
and the approach the combined approach
that i
i presented you will solve this in in
nine hours
a second example is a partially
observable markov position process
where you basically depending on the
location
in this maze where you are you are not
able to distinguish one
location from another location so it's
partially observable
and this is very hard so determining an
optimal strategy
for instance to reach the exit of such a
maze is actually undecidable
so therefore and this has to do to the
fact that those strategies need infinite
memory
so if you restrict the memory for
instance you use only positional
strategies
i mean memory basically only the current
state
then you can actually solve this as an
optimal positional strategy but this
is hard this is etr complete which is
between
etr complexity class is between np
and p space and this is intuitively
speaking as hard as finding the real
roots of a polynomial
so what we want to do is actually
solving this hard problem
and in practice what you're considering
is actually you consider finite
state controllers with a finite amount
of memory
and these can also be randomized
so here is an example of such of such a
maze
you see for instance that these
positions i mean equally colored
positions
are uh basically the same that means
you cannot distinguish between being in
position five
and being in position ten and you're
interested in minimizing the expected
number of steps to exit the maze
and in this example we have one bit of
memory
so what you see for instance here it
says no matter what will be the memory
that says is x don't care
then we basically set the memory bit to
0 and we move from 11 to 8.
and actually this has a model with 22
parameters
9.4 million possible strategies the
markov chain itself is very small
but still the number of markov chains to
consider is is of course large
the baseline takes about two days and in
our approach you can compute
the optimal one in one hour and actually
the optimal one
is indicated in the in the plot that i
showed you on the left
to conclude i like to come back to the
hammond's randomized self-stabilizing
algorithm i showed you in the beginning
notice that there we just had a bias
coin
and the bias coin is just based on your
variable value comparing with that of
your left neighbor
now what happens if you are maybe having
a more powerful strategy
maybe if you have some memory and notice
something about the past can you then
improve can you then basically get
a smaller expected convergence type
and this turns out to be the case so you
can for instance consider a model with a
single bit of memory and to make the
problem discrete let's say that there
are 25 different
coin biases that you can pick from and
in our setting this means we have seven
parameters 3.1 million possible
strategies
and each markov chain having about 1 000
states and the baseline takes one and a
half days
and the technique that i just explained
you to you can solve this in
17 minutes and actually what you get is
a strategy which is not
completely obvious uh namely initially
you use most fair coins and you have
your memory bit set to zero
and later which means if you're
possessing the token
you try to maximize the probability to
to
keep the token and actually then you're
going to use highly unfair coins with a
memory bit of one
so you can let's say automatically
synthesize
non-trivial strategies using this kind
of technique
i'd like to wrap up um i hope to have
shown you a couple of
uh examples i did not show you software
product lines i only mentioned it
um keep in mind that we use both seeger
and sigis as well as their combination
um well i'm the first to admit that this
is
definitely initial work in this
direction um i think there are a lot
of things that can be improved
refinement strategies which i didn't
explain in detail to you in this talk we
also want to look at other models
not only markov chains and not only
finite families but also infinite
families and so forth
here are some pointers for for further
reference if you're interested and
there will be a tool soon in which this
all
is available to you thanks a lot
thank you very much uh yes peter great
talk have time for a short question
doesn't need to ask a
question please raise your hand uh hi
youth peter here is here is russ uh
thank you for a nice talk just a quick
question you uh sort of made a
distinction between program and
uh markov chains is there a translation
between them can you tell us maybe
quickly a bit more
how you get from one to the other
yeah there is for i mean depending on
what kind of programming constructs you
allow there is a
translation from uh for instance prism
programs but also other kind of programs
into markov chains
uh the only point is that they don't
have to be finite so here we restrict
ourselves to
finite state programs right
if you allow non-determinism then your
program is no longer a markov chain but
it becomes a markov decision process
thank you all right so i have a short
question so
you are showing these families so uh we
listened to a talk that was using
libraries you know and the idea was to
share as much as
possible the code you know so do you
think that it would be possible in your
case to
to have like a sharing of uh sub
programs you know such that uh
you build incrementally you know this
way simplify this industry
i think this would be possible yeah
i don't see anything
so you mean you create family members by
basically identifying which shared
components which shared
pieces they have so to speak and
assemble
uh other programs from it right yeah
it's like like creating objects you know
with incrementally having methods such
that you
i think you share as much as possible
thank you very much again uh let's give
to your speaker and let's uh
introduce now our next speaker who is
kim